et pour y parvenir il vous faudra
certainement quelques petits accessoires
et surtout surtout suivre les conseils
de notre duo de choc thierry fuseaux et
son élève et mystérieux là
et oui aujourd'hui on vous proposait une
mise en place donc sur le thème de noël
alors une mise en place qui commence va
naturellement par un apajh avec un
chemin de table ce chemin de table rouge
que amy va habiller avec les ardoises
lorsqu'il est en face à face de
personnes changent de nom et s'appelle
au final un tête à tête
alors on a décidé et mis à décider parce
que c'est elle qui a construit de cette
mise en place elle a réfléchi de partir
sur des ardoises des ardoises de toi
tout simplement parce qu'elles ont pour
avantage d'être très plate et de servir
de sets de table et en même temps de
pouvoir personnaliser un petit message
dessus voilà un petit clin d'oeil à
l'émission et puis au final on peut
aussi faire un petit clin d'oeil aux
invités qui vont venir autour de cette
table de noël pour marquer les places et
servir de marque place alors on change
un petit peu les codes avec emi on
positionne découvert non pas fourchettes
à gauche plutôt à droite mais un petit
peu en diagonale sur le lieu de
l'assiette pour histoire d'animer un
petit peu le la table et puis après bien
sûr un repas de fête qui dit repas de
fête du bois sont donc deux verres
toujours sur la table de noël un verre à
eau un verre à vin de préférence de la
hauteur donc des grands verres à vin
pour pouvoir bien faire respirer le vin
et puis les petites touches de
décoration le pain avec l'assiette à
pain là c'est à pas en terme de position
va toujours là positionné à gauche en
fait le liquide sur table se met
toujours à droite et le solide à gauche
donc voilà c'est à pain à gauche
quelques éléments de décor qui vont nous
permettre de pouvoir animer la table
avec les petites étoiles qu'on va
retrouver sur la serviette et une
serviette qu'un petit pliage un peu
festif cette année puisqu'on vous
propose le pliage du sa fin amy va vous
montrer ça dans un instant le ménage
bien sûr le duo sel et poivre
et puis donc quelques petites
décorations pour venir finir d'habiller
cette table
hop et on vous propose donc de regarder
le pliage de serviettes avec amy alors
en fait c'est tout simple on vous a
choisi vraiment quelque chose de
réalisable à la maison on part sur inès
une serviette carré on va là plié en
deux en rectangle et l'art plié en deux
pour redevenir un carré et de là on va
rabattre tous les angles vers soir en
laissant un bon centimètre entre le bord
de la serviette
et puis le pli on va donc le faire
quatre fois et ça ça va nous donner tout
à l'heure les épines les branches du
sapin la serviette
on la retourne skis et le bas de la
serviette face à amy va devenir le haut
du sapin
donc elle plie de façon à avoir vraiment
une pointe en haut pour faire le sommet
on la retourne une dernière fois et là
la magie s'opère en laissant en faisant
apparaître au final les branches du
sapin pour pouvoir bloquer en même temps
c'est petit et puis on va devenir
décoincer les uns sous les autres voilà
l'idée c'est d'avoir une base très plate
et puis de pouvoir et bien ensuite la
disposer sur table qui on peut la
décorer avec des petites étoiles on peut
aussi animer la table avec
éventuellement des bougies on a deux
choisi amy a choisi la une une bougie en
pommes de pin d'ailleurs vous aviez tout
à l'heure au démarrage de la séquence ce
petit ces petits symboles de noël qui va
permettre donc justement de décorer
l'ensemble est belle et justement je
vais venir mettre la petite touche
finale à notre table de fête et je sais
pas pour vous mais moi je suis prête
pour le foie gras